D
TAKE JUST A MATTER OF DAYS.
>> ALL RIGHT, MOALA LENGHI, THAK
YOU.
JOINING US NOW IS ASHISH AJA
DEAN OF BROWN PUBLIC SCHOOL OF
HEALTH.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU HERE.
>> THANKS, GAYLE.
>> PFIZER APPROVING KIDS 12 AND
OVER.
DO THEY GET THE SAME DOSE AS THE
ADULTS?
AND DO YOU HAVE ANY CONCERN
ABOUT CHILDREN GETTING IT?
>> SO, I DON'T HAVE ANY
CONCERNS.
THE DOSING WILL BE -- WE'LL GET
THE DETAILS ON THE DOSING FROM
THE FDA.
WE'VE SEEN IN THE CLINICAL
TRIALS THAT KIDS HAVE TOLERATED
THIS VERY, VERY WELL.
AND IT'S BEEN HIGHLY EFFECTIVE.
SO, I HAVE TWO KIDS IN THAT AGE
RANGE, AND THEY'RE BOTH VERY
EXCITED TO GET IT.
AND I'M HAPPY FOR THEM TO GET IT
BECAUSE I REALLY DO THINK THE
VACCINES ARE REMARKABLY
EFFECTIVE AND QUITE SAFE.
>> OKAY.
I WAS WONDERING IF YOUR OTHER
THAN CHILDREN WERE GOING TO GET
IT.
WHAT ABOUT THE TIME LINE FOR
HERD IMMUNITY?
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ABOUT
WE STARTED OUT WE NEED 70%, 80%,
90%.
AND NOW WE'RE NOWHERE CLOSE TO
THAT.
>> RIGHT.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S A LOT MADE OUT
OF HERD IMMUNITY.
LOOK, WE THINK IT'S ABOUT 80% OF
PEOPLE NEED TO HAVE IMMUNITY
BEFORE WE GET THERE.
WE'RE ACTUALLY PRETTY FAR ALONG.
I THINK IF WE CAN GET ANOTHER
10% OR 15% OF AMERICANS TO GET
VACCINATED I THINK IT WILL
ACTUALLY MAKE AN ENORMOUS
DIFFERENCE.
WHETHER WE HIT THAT MAGIC NUMBER
OR NOT, INFECTION NUMBERS WILL
COME WAY, WAY DOWN.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE CARE ABOUT.
AND LIFE WILL GO BACK TO KIND OF
A NEW VERSION OF NORMAL.
I THINK WE SHOULD WORRY LESS
ABOUT THAT.
AND CONTINUE FOCUSING ON GETTING
MORE PEOPLE VACCINATED.
THAT'S HOW WE'RE GOING TO GET
BACK TO NORMAL.
>> YEAH, I WONDER IF HERD
IMMUNITY IS EVEN POSSIBLE.
I WONDER ABOUT THAT.
>> YOU KNOW, IT WILL VARY FROM
PLACE TO PLACE.
THERE WILL BE COMMUNITIES, THERE
WILL BE STATES THAT IMMUNITY
LEVELS MAY BE SO HIGH THEY MAY
HIT HERD IMMUNITY THERE.
OTHER STATES MAY BE LOWER.
OVERALL AS A COUNTRY WE MAY HAVE
A HARD TIME GETTING IT.
WHAT I CARE THE MOST ABOUT, CAN
WE GET THE INFECTIONS LOW SAND
MAKE IT SAFE TO GET BACK TO OUR
LIVES.
I THINK WE CAN.
>> I WENT OUT TO BRUNCH WITH MY
NIECE AND NEPHEW THE FIRST TIME
I LEFT MY KITCHEN TABLE IN A
YEAR AND A HALF.
80% TO 90% OF PEOPLE WERE STILL
WEARING THEIR MASK.
MYSELF INCLUDED.
I TOOK IT OFF AND IT WAS WEIRD
TO TAKE IT OFF.
IS IT OKAY?
MANY PEOPLE SAY IT'S OKAY TO
TAKE YOUR MASK OFF OUTSIDE, YOU
SAY, YEAH, YOU CAN, VACCINE OR
NOT, TRUE?
>> YEAH, OUTSIDE, VACCINE OR NOT
IT IS OKAY IF YOU'RE NOT GOING
TO BE AROUND CROWDS AND IF
YOU'RE VACCINATED, IT'S
EXCEEDINGLY SAFE TO HAVE YOUR
MASK OFF OUTSIDE.
I WOULD NOT WORRY ABOUT IT IF
YOU'RE VACCINATED.
>> ALL OF A SUDDEN, I FETE VERY
NAKED.
NEW YORK IS TALKING ABOUT
LIFTING -- OPENING UP IN THE
NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS.
IS THIS A GOOD MOVE FOR US?
>> YEAH, I DO.
I THINK NEW YORK'S MOVE IS A
GOOD MOVE.
NEW YORK HAS DONE A GREAT JOB OF
GETTING PEOPLE VACCINATED.
INFECTION NUMBERS ARE PLUMMETING
THERE.
OVER THE NEXT FEW WEEKS
INFECTION NUMBERS ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO COME DOWN.
THE KEY HERE, WE GOT TO KEEP
VACCINATING.
WE CAN'T LET OUR FOOT OFF THE
ACCELERATOR THERE.
TH